because you're uh like Asia culture do
you guys call in sick when you're sick I
think you if you do it's kind of like
look down right you gotta be dying just
tough it out I called out one my dad was
like why are you here I'm oh no I'm I'm
digged dude oh work right now when
you're working you're gonna sweat the
flu out
let's just show up and have them kick
you out when they kicked you out I was
like it's not your fault so you feel
more like okay if you want me to leave
Johnson I'll leave you know I want to
work no get the hell out of here you'll
get a sick okay come home and be like
let's go do something I'm like sure you
rest I mean you're sick let's go to the
river